[Laughter]
[Music]
this will be funny doing it with you i
think we'll get some good answers out of
this and you guys i don't think i was
talking about any of the [ __ ] i was
supposed to do
yeah yeah
what are you supposed to do
it's gonna be like
that was stupid
you know what this is
management doesn't know what they're
talking about this is the way to get
more people to
listen to your [ __ ] and follow your [ __ ]
because you just go on a show like this
and they like you and that's it
you guys man
i've had a trip watching some of it so
this is
pretty cool you appreciate that
would you rather have 50 grand straight
to your bank account or half a million
in pennies
am i supposed to read yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i don't know if it's a game
or something
would you rather have 50 grand straight
to your bank account or half a million
in pennies and you can't convert it
also you're probably rich so maybe we
got to up those numbers a little bit i
don't know
i don't know what number moves the
needle for you but
i'm gonna have to take the pennies bro
what are you gonna do with the pennies
better than [ __ ]
for the copper yeah
when the dollar crumbles
very good it would also be cool to just
dump them in like a wishing fountain
[Laughter]
just just one fountain
half a million pennies
half a million dollars
that would be funny
like a really small like european alps
kind of town
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
aliens who would
oh [ __ ]
um
there's an obvious funny answer to this
i think well i mean it depends on
whether or not we're being common core
if we want to take a seriously
that's
[Laughter]
no you know why the aliens would be like
oh we've been waiting for you
dad's gonna roll up his back
i haven't seen you boys in a minute
welcome home
[Music]
he is a wild one
yeah it worked in north korea
all right
would you watch your buddies sex tape
with their ex
that's it
some of them are so weird
would you watch
a sex tape with this like like if you
had a sex tape with your ex and i came
across it would i watch it and the
answer is hell yes o'connor
you would i'll watch anybody you want to
watch me [ __ ] you yeah make fun of you
man yeah
i want to do that
a little bit with the camera angle right
yeah that's a great point
it's a great movie for being honest yeah
why don't you
wide screen from far away maybe if we're
getting up in there i don't know i don't
want to see that is she hot yeah yeah
yeah
but my answer man i'm a married man with
two kids absolutely not
you know and i wouldn't want to be
disrespectful to his ex
i feel like that's also one of those
things that would start funny and then
you'd be like what am i doing here
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god
would you rather everyone be naked all
the time or closed all the time
that's a double-edged sword yeah it is
and all the time all the time like you
shower you gotta shower in your clothes
you're in church
you're in yeah you go to bed you're uh
wherever you either gotta be naked all
the time or a clothes all the time you
gotta see your grandma naked yeah your
boss all the ugly people in the world
you're walking down the street anything
you know where you go to just everything
oh i didn't think about funerals
naked
if you get a boner at that funeral yeah
[Laughter]
be it's not the best but it's better
than nate i think i would go close yeah
you got to yeah
can you still [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's on though
all drive rubbed no no
yeah i'm gonna go with clothes have you
seen some of the clothes you've gotten
out cause clothes could be
yeah great point yeah you got fashion
overnight do you see what some of these
cyclists are wearing
[Laughter]
a [ __ ] loin club
yeah
are these really like just [ __ ] people
since y'all yeah yeah
i don't even know this [ __ ] guy would
you watch your buddy
he totally did it yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah
you know what a lot of them actually
come from like this happened to me what
would you guys do so that one probably
was a real yeah no
he was just sitting there staring at
like his buddy's phone being like i
gotta ask the boys
[Laughter]
just hoping to reach out to someone's
like you guys do this too right like you
would totally do it
would you switch your painting size with
your foot size how big's that foot
what's that what size we got that's a
damn 11.
but
no matter what it's a yes oh
the sickest answer to this is like it's
a wasp
that's apples for apples i probably have
some pretty serious balance issues
my dick
let's do a couple more for you
you can be quiet sneaking up on them
be like being on your tippy toes
[Laughter]
what is the one food you could eat for
the rest of your life
[Laughter]
probably the heartbeat was coming i was
gonna say
pizza yeah
we finally got it
you know it was terrible pizza yeah
[Music]
you can't run that [ __ ]
i was going to say we finally got around
to the thing your management wanted you
to talk
[Laughter]
nailed it
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon